[Music]
my name is Matt DAW I live in Brooklyn
New York we've got a shop in Greenpoint
where I work on motorcycles we're gonna
be deconstructing in 1974
harley-davidson shovel head shovel heads
a nickname actually for the model it's
kind of like there's different eras
there's a knucklehead the panhead the
shovel head and these are all nicknames
that were given by different motorcycle
riders because of the way they look so
the top rocker boxes on the motor which
are the very top chrome pieces with the
two nuts look like shovels the pan heads
have like a more rounded shape they look
like bands and the knuckleheads have two
very distinct nuts at the top with a
contoured cast rocker top we're gonna
strip it down beards as minimal as it
can with the motor and transmission
staying intact everything else
disassembled completely before we
started this process I've drained all
the fluids already the oil on the gas to
make sure everything is dry when
removing the gas tanks you want to make
sure there's no gasoline inside you want
to make sure the engine and the primary
is free of oil because otherwise you're
gonna have a mess when you take
everything apart once all that is
cleaned out and dried that's when you
start the process of dismantling the
bike I call from my toolbox as needed
and reset at different intervals
throughout the deconstruction right here
I've already got my Phillips head screw
driver out taking out the rear screw on
the seat there are two tongues in the
front that slide under the frame which
keep it secured in the front it's an
aftermarket seat kind of a little
sleeker design than the stock after
removing the seat you have access to the
battery and electrical area what you
want to do then is disconnect the
battery and the reason you want to
disconnect the battery before you do
anything else is because when working on
the bike you're using metal tools your
hands
everywhere you don't want to
accidentally ground something or engage
the starter by accident or really give
the bike any reason to have electricity
running through it I'm gonna disconnect
the ground terminal and the positive
terminal I was very determined to find a
bike that I was going to ride as opposed
to take apart and I found the bike in
Albany
like I was asking a fair price and
bought a van and put my dog in the back
and drove up to Albany he got up out of
bed at midnight helped me push the bike
in the back of the van and that was it
we drove back that night this right now
what I'm taking off is the air cleaner
cover for the carburetor underneath this
is an air filter this is kind of a
classic it's called an S & S it's a tear
drop style it's an aftermarket
performance company for Harley's and
it's their iconic air cleaner
next we're gonna start taking off the
gas tank normally there is a speedo
right in the center where my hands are
at this moment that will give you your
mileage reading your speed
sometimes there's tachometer involved
which takes a rpm reading from the motor
generally necessary for inspections but
also flies under the wire for a lot of
guys who want custom bikes parlays
always had and probably always will have
a very cult following it's very much
more organic and like the following is
much more organic behind it you know and
there's all the myth and the ethos
behind of Harley being American and
there's not quite the same thing for any
other brand as much as there are
extremists and purists for every other
brand it doesn't carry the same kind of
culture around it there's plenty of
other companies that have nicknames on
motors that people make up but nothing
sticks nobody's gonna call this an FX e
most of the time it's just a shovel head
I started working on bikes when I was 18
years old got my first bike couldn't
afford to have anybody else work on it
so I had to learn from there and that
was kind of bumming around and getting
information where I could and hanging
around the shops and poking my head
places it didn't belong was open up my
own shop at one point in Newfoundland in
Canada which is where I'm from after
closing up shop there for an opportunity
in New York I've been here working on
motorcycles doing custom fabrication
ever since there's three points on these
specific gas tanks where the hardware is
mounted so you've got the two top mounts
then there's one at the bottom of the
frame where there's a little tab these
specific ones are two pieces that are
connected by lines in the center for
venting and gas flow Billy's here with
me assisting me today and everything
that I'm taking off the bike he's taking
off camera and organizing labeling and
making sure everything stays together
where it should be
one side of these tanks is vented the
other is not which creates a positive
pressure flow which is what creates all
the gas going from one side to the other
there's only one outlet to the
carburetor which is through what's
called a petcock the petcock is a valve
there's three settings there's on/off
and reserve the reserve is at a height
level it saves you from being stuck on
the side of the road the best way to do
it is to run it on and if you do haven't
run out of gas that reserve will get you
another 15 20 miles depends
the size of your tank now that the tanks
are off we're gonna go over and take off
the carburetor start from the manifold
and work our way out this is what feeds
the engine this is your first line the
fuel comes in
it's very specifically designed to give
it a certain air fuel mixture what I
just did there was remove the throttle
cable or the throttle control is on the
right hand side of the handlebars you
twist it the cable pulls it opens the
carburetor that's what controls how much
air and fuel goes into the engine at any
time which is what controls your speed
so this is an SNS superbee carb this one
has an interesting aftermarket part that
has an accelerator pump which wasn't
common of the era the accelerator pump
basically when you crank the throttle
shoots a little bit extra gas into the
motor first so on startup and first the
initial acceleration it kind of makes
you go a little bit quicker right here
I'm removing the top motor mount to the
engine which connects the two cylinder
heads to the top of the frame throughout
this process are going to be using
standard hand tools wrenches ratchets
sockets screwdrivers and various allen
keys the reason to use hand tools on a
bike it's just efficient and also it's
really important in a lot of
circumstances to feel to actually
physically get a sense of feel for the
bike so you know if you're going to
strip a bolt if you're gonna share
something whereas if you had a power
tool if you were trying to remove
something with like an impact gun you
wouldn't be able to actually feel the
tension on the bolt and you could end up
breaking something and it turns into a
whole of that process of like bolt
removal and huge problems there's three
mounting points traditionally on most
Harley's you've got your front and your
rear motor mounts and then you talk
motor mount I'm trying to remove the
clamps for the manifold so I take off
the motor mount first and then have
access to the clamps the motor mount it
actually makes the engine itself a
structural member of the whole chassis
in this model it's rigid mounted there's
no buffer dampening system between the
motor and the frame it's all Hardware
metal-to-metal full contact whereas in
later models you have high rubber
dampers a lot of like poly the bike
itself is pretty
standard it's almost 45 years old it's
close to stock as it can be with some
bolt-on modifications this model in
particular is the FX e which is the
Super Glide
that was the denotation of the era the e
stands for electric start where you
could get them at the time with
kickstart only or kick and electric
start which was a new introduction for
Harley of this era of like the 69 up
shovel heads here I'm removing both
clamps and then it's just a little bit
of a wiggle and a pull and it's out now
I'm going to get in and start taking
apart the exhaust pipes basically the
whole process here from the air cleaner
now to the exhaust pipes is your
stripping everything off of the engine
so you can have access to the engine to
remove it easily that's your main goal
that's a big milestone and taking apart
the bike is getting the motor and
transmission out these exhaust pipes on
the Shovelhead they have one bolt on
each manifold but hold them in and then
the exhaust leads to a bracket which is
attached to the frame and then attached
to the rear of the exhaust as well see
it's mounted on multiple points these
are an aftermarket pipes they're not
baffled so they're very loud they don't
add to performance in any kind of way
because there's two cylinders there's
one exhaust pipe for each cylinder in
this and most Road motorcycles with
street motorcycles are four-stroke
there's four different movements of the
piston to make the bike move one sucks
in the air the other pushes up and
creates a combustion the fuel then it
drops down again
then on the fourth stroke is when it
pushes out the exhaust so it's all in
rhythm and if you have something that's
out of rhythm your bikes not going to
run right and one thing that's important
that is the back pressure in the exhaust
so if your exhaust is escaping too
quickly the whole system is thrown out
of whack it's kind of like music you
know
another way to think of it is like a
pulse so there's like a say like every
two seconds is a pop-pop-pop-pop but if
it can't produce that right rhythm the
rest of the engines gonna run bad the
motorcycle is going to run off one of
the main stylistic features in custom
motorcycles is custom exhaust you can
get aftermarket mufflers but build all
the rest of the exhaust from scratch or
build straight pipes like these with no
with no baffles and you just build the
whole thing these are what came on the
bike they wouldn't necessarily be my
choice aesthetically but this is what
what came on the bike and high-end
exhaust systems can be very expensive
now that I have the exhaust off I'm
working on taking off the hardware this
specific exhaust system has slotted
hardware which actually slides into the
back of the exhaust it's a really common
system for most aftermarket and stock
exhaust brackets now I'm taking off the
forward Highway pegs these are an added
accessory not necessary to riding it
whatsoever it's more for comfort on
longer trips when you can like stretch
your legs out
and this here the kickstand is also
attached to to the left side of the
highway peg here the kickstand obviously
is what holds the bike up when it's not
mounted on a lift somewhere so many
varieties of kick stands and different
operations this is a very common one for
shovel heads I'm taking off the voltage
regulator which controls the flow to the
battery alternator creates AC current
and the AC current goes to the regulator
which converts it to DC and sends it to
the battery the output of the alternator
depends on the RPM of the motor which
sends so much electricity to the
regulator the regulator basically takes
all that and says here's 12 volts it
regulates everything so the battery is
not going to explode all right now I'm
removing the right side brake pedal and
foot peg this is a standard brake mount
setup for this kind of bike it mounts to
the transmission and tab on the frame so
this is just the bracket that holds the
foot peg and the brake pedal on here I'm
taking off the bolts for the exhaust
bracket the reason I'm doing this
because the exhaust bracket is holding
the master cylinder the master cylinder
is what holds the hydraulic brake fluid
where these have a disc brake setup on
the bike it's run by pressure there's a
plunger at the end of the brake pedal
that engages the plunger system in the
master cylinder which on the other side
translates to fluid pressure and now
that I've got everything disconnected
I'm removing the brake pedal on the foot
peg from the bike
just continuing with the brake system
taking off the exhaust bracket and then
taking off the master cylinder they
stopped producing the show led in 1984
and switch to the Evo which was
nicknamed a blockhead but that didn't
really stick a lot of the old bikers
thought Harley lost his spirit in that
era so these are still like the
nostalgic bikes the pan had the
knucklehead to show LED I'm removing the
starter solenoid which engages the
starter it's part of the electric start
system electrical is kind of the biggest
mess you'll see on any bike especially
an old bike because everybody thinks
they have the right idea and nobody
really understands there's a lot of
electrical tape and zip ties on stuff
that shouldn't be there there's a lot of
like snipping and picking when taking a
bike apart there's a certain amount of
room to change the process but you need
to stick within certain confines like
you can't take out the motor before you
take off the gas tank there's also a
step-by-step process to follow that you
need to stick to fairly rigidly to get
everything apart the right way so right
now the battery tray is coming out
underneath mounted to that battery trays
that starter relay which sends the
signal to the starter solenoid which
then sends the signal to the starter
motor which is just an electric motor
that engages a gear system and literally
pumps the engine over till it starts on
removing the left side shifter peg
[Applause]
and Here I am just removing the foot peg
as well just one bolt that holds it on
really simple it's really basic normal
foot peg setup for this bike here we are
removing the inspection cover on the
primary this is the inspection cover
itself it's called that because when
you're doing maintenance on the bike you
can remove this cover and check the
primary drive chain tension just kind of
see what's going on in there you pop it
open you look inside you check your
chain tension it's minimally invasive to
do the maintance you need to do here
removing the derby cover once removing
this it gives you access to the clutch
basket it's what transfers the power
from the engine to the transmission then
the transmission after going through the
gear ratios in whatever configuration
sends the power to through the rear
wheel
now removing the full-auto primary cover
because again we're fully dismantling
the bike you need to take off the
primary cover to get access to the
inside of the primary to take off the
inner primary which then gives you
access to removing the motor there's
Billy cleaning the parts as they're
coming off the bike this is a parts
washer it's a 45 gallon drum of kerosene
and pump and this is a housing that sits
on top of the drum and the pump it's
just a recirc pump it sucks up the
kerosene shoots it at that nozzle and
then goes back down the drain just does
that over and over and over again and
what that does is it cleans all the
grease and gunk and whatnot from engine
parts the one thing that's really
important that every nut and bolt every
piece of hardware everything that comes
off should all be bagged and organized
labeled because when the time comes
eventually put it back together you want
to know what everything is you can't put
all the nuts and bolts in one box and
figure it out later so when everything
comes off the primary everything gets
labeled primary hardware when everything
comes off the foot controls everything
gets labeled foot control hardware every
single unit on the bike that has its own
specific hardware has to stay or be
labeled I've had the shop here almost
two years fully on my own but I've had a
workshop now privately for four years
I mostly deal with Harley's but any
background any kind of custom
fabrication it always kind of welcome in
the shop high-end motorcycle fabrication
it's kind of the specialty the most
integral thing that you need before
touching your motorcycle is getting the
factory service manual every single
motorcycle has a book if you bring your
bike to a mechanic the mechanic has that
book for your bike because you don't
want to adjust anything you don't want
to change anything if you don't know
what you're doing and you won't know
what you're doing until you open up the
service mail for this specific bike and
you go from there every instruction you
could ever need to work on a motorcycle
is in a service manual
[Music]
here's the clutch clutch basket clutch
hub will remove that the adjustment nut
on the clutch is through a threaded rod
a threaded arm with a flat head
adjustment to lock it in the flat head
screwdriver fits into the threaded piece
and the lock nut is how you tighten it
up so you take that off completely
completely remove any kind of tension
system and then you put on a washer that
sits around the ring of the clutch
springs and when you tighten that up
what that does is because the washer is
there it forces the springs tight that
gives you the opportunity to loosen all
the nuts that have pressure on them so
you take all those nuts off completely
and then you back off the clutch
adjustment screw and when you back off
the clutch adjustment screw is when you
remove everything else all the springs
come out of the clutch you can remove
the clutch basket and there's a million
little pieces in there all the pressure
plates for the clutch the basic thing
that you start with is remove the chain
tensioner the chain tensioner is the
unit there that's in between the two
sprockets
it's a polyurethane slide basically that
you adjust the height up and down
because over time your chains going to
stretch what the tensioner does is keep
it within spec once the clutch is fully
removed move to the front and take off
the compensator not the one thing to
note about this is that it's reverse
threaded the reason this reverse started
is because of the motion of the engine
if it were moving in the same direction
as a classic right hand threaded thread
which is standard for everything it
would loosen itself so what it does is
the opposite actually tightens itself
this is one of the specific times where
you use an impact gun on the bike
everything else is not really necessary
most engines especially outside of
Crawley design they have what's called
like a unit construction so the
transmission and the motor are all in
one case this is a completely separate
so the motor transmission are completely
separate from each other in this other
attached once you get the clutch plates
out you need what's called a clutch hub
puller which is a specific tool for this
job it mounts onto the fingers of the
clutch hub that you just removed the
nuts and the springs from and then
there's basically just a big bolt and
you crank on that you can do it by hand
if necessary but it's kind of difficult
the right way to do is with an impact
and you just crank it and what it does
is it forces that bolt in pushes against
the transmission shaft and then pulls
the hub of the clutch off so it comes
off as a unit there's different ways to
stop up the clutch hub from actually
moving is a very basic way of that like
I have to screwdriver and shove it in
between the forks and you just kind of
go to town what's actually happening is
it's forcing the clutch hub to be pulled
off of the shaft this clutch hub puller
in particular you can see there's a
bunch of holes in the faceplate and it's
because this one is actually set up for
multiple kinds of clutch baskets and
different kinds of bikes it does almost
every single kind of removal because of
the whole layout there's like multiple
different holey outs on that one plate
and then you just remove all the inner
primary Hardware to remove the inner
primary itself we've got a pry bar it's
got a little rubber foot on it it's
something that you incorporate as
necessary you don't want to have metal
on metal as much as possible that guy's
got a little rubber foot for leverage
it's again it's by feel a lot of times
if you need to use a pry bar you want to
put a wooden block or some kind of
rubber some kind of buffer between the
metal so you don't scratch it not always
necessary I just use it because it's
efficient we're almost down to the bare
motor and transmission that's the
turning point and taking apart the bike
once the motor transmission out you've
already done all the hard stuff and it's
just kind of taking boats off and you
don't have as much to worry about after
that
I'm just taking off the shifter arm from
the transmission that was attached to
the shift leaver that we removed earlier
the shift lever that we removed earlier
is just linkage that sends a direction
to that and then the shifter I'm changes
this gears in the inside the
transmission the transmission itself is
a four-speed later models five-speed
6-speed 6-speed is generally an
overdrive gear for highway riding here
what happened when removing the shifter
arm one of the allen head bolts that
were holding the shift arm to the drum
and one of them was stripped and so what
I did is I took a similar-sized Torx
head socket and hammered it in because
the bolt afterwards isn't salvageable
anyway so you basically forced something
in that is a similar shape but the Torx
head has almost a spiked or a star
pattern so it forces itself in and then
you can hopefully get the bolt removed
fairly easily so what I'm doing here is
I'm just popping a couple of the the
bolts back in to keep the cover on the
shifter I'm there once all the
hardware's removed and we've already
removed the carburetor any kind of
sensitive equipment once these four
bolts are removed you can just slide the
motor out from the side in other bikes
there's different ways to do it but this
is what works for this show hood I would
say the end is around 150 pounds off the
top of my head it's definitely not light
I'm taking off the right side of the
rear motor mount hardware there's four
mounting points you just kind of work
your way around the bike to get it all
out of there right now actually what I'm
doing is removing the oil lines that
feed the oil pump and return from the
oil pump when removing the oil lines
everything is attached by hose clamps
here which are engaged with a flat head
screwdriver flat head warm drive one of
the lines itself had become hard and dry
and so the best thing to do because all
these lines are gonna have to get
replaced in an old bike like this anyway
is just to cut it and makes the process
a lot quicker I'm making sure all the
oil lines are disconnected and all the
hardware's removed from the motor mounts
we're going to go ahead and pull the
motor out of the frame there's mounting
hardware on the top that keeps his
rocker boxes attached to the motor and
everybody wants to put their flavor on
their bike what happened here is that
there's a corn nuts put on which are
basically a blind
that have a little crown on top they're
not through you can't tighten them
they're decorative the problem with the
acorn nuts in this scenario is that they
were too tall and we couldn't pull the
motor from the frame directly so one of
the acorn nuts on the rocker box had to
be removed to get the motor out of the
frame here we're pulling the engine
right out of the frame this is the first
time this bikes ever been fully
disassembled since it's been mine we're
discovering a lot along the ways we're
taking everything apart the transmission
itself is mounted to a plate and the
plate is mounted to the frame the
transmission plate is fixed to the frame
in a fixed position the slots that the
transmission is mounted to can move back
and forth a forward mass basically and
what that does is it gives you adjust
meant for the primary tension if
necessary what it's really for is
alignment here I'm actually removing the
chain from the bike and that's just to
be able to pull the transmission out
easier because removing the change from
that sprocket otherwise it would get
caught up and kind of kind of tangled
I'm using a chain breaker here the chain
breaker drives the pin through the side
and out the other side and so it removes
one of the pins so you can break the
chain basically your engine is creating
whatever RPM whatever power that you're
giving it through the throttle which
comes through the carburetor and the gas
so that then has to be transferred
through something because otherwise if
you had it directly hooked up to your
rear wheel your rear wheel would spin at
exactly the same rate or whatever gear
ratio you had set up by sprocket as the
motor so the transmission is the
go-between so you've got four speeds at
different ratios that translated into
smooth power to the rear wheel so if you
didn't have a transmission it would
literally be a single speed and that
single speed would be determined at by
the RPM of the motor
[Music]
suddenly our into is this piece of
hardware is actually preventing the
transmission from coming out of the
frame so it's just something to pop off
really quick to make sure that you've
got clean access to get everything out
of there without having again without
having to force it you never want to
force anything like this mantling
motorcycle at all because if you're
forcing it you're doing it wrong now the
transmission is coming out of the frame
just kind of got a wiggle it around a
little bit to get clear of everything
this is an electric start model but for
this error what that meant is a head
electric start in addition to kick start
so it transfers electrical power in a
mechanical power but with the kickstart
system it's straight force like physical
force so you use that kick start as a
lever to physically turn over the motor
with your leg so that's what creates the
cycle and when using a kick start what
we're doing here is removing the
bar from the fender struts this is an
aftermarket add-on and basically all it
is is just mounts to the finish struts
it's a unit that you can like mount any
kind of like baggage again it's not
something that comes standard on all
bikes but it's something that is kind of
like iconic to the era after we have the
bar removed detach the rest of the
hardware that holds the fender to the
fender struts and right now the way that
I've done it is I've left the rear
taillight attached and all the wiring
just because whenever this goes back
together it's just easier to
plug-and-play all back in now that we
have the fender off we're going to
remove the rear wheel very basic it's
just rod with a threaded nut at the end
that goes through I like the axle you
take off the nut on one side and you
have to drive the axle all the way
through the hub to get the wheel out
once you get the axle out you just pull
the wheel out super easy
there are spacers on either side of the
hub that keep the wheel centered where
it needs to be in line with the chassis
so those spacers are really important
they can't be loose they can't be too
tight especially on early style or
Timken style bearings like this now that
we've got the rear wheel off removing
the rear brake caliper I'm taking off
the rear brake caliper as a unit with
the brake arm and the brake line the
rear brake caliper is the housing that
holds the brake pads the brake pads
around the rotor what happens is the
plunger that we discussed earlier that
goes into the master cylinder transfers
the pressure and then the fluid pressure
is actually what pushes the little
pistons inside the brake caliper to
engage and all it is is force so the
brake pads literally get pressed up onto
the rotor and that's what stops the bike
[Music]
right here I'm removing the rear
passenger pegs these pegs in particular
are some aftermarket passenger pegs that
mount directly to the frame with a clamp
style system you'll see a million
different kinds of these now that we've
got those removed I'm gonna go ahead and
start removing the rear shocks basically
this is a rear suspension system so when
you're riding down the road this is what
provides the comfort the way that I
learned in the way that I came up in
this industry is just by hard work and
problem-solving and that's kind of the
way that I tackle every project now is
it really it's it's the passion behind
it that lets me use my creativity to
develop something but it's about
problem-solving along the way that's a
part of the hurdles or what you have to
get over it's all part of the fun
once you remove the rear shocks you can
drop the rear swingarm and then you can
take off the rest of the fender struts
[Music]
now here we are removing the headlight
on the bike now I'm taking the hand
controls off of the handlebars right
there I'd remove the clutch lever and
the line and now I'm removing the
throttle and the throttle cable as well
[Music]
and right there I'm removing a front
brake lever once all that's removed I
can take the bolts out of the handlebars
and take the handlebars off of the
triple tree of the fork now I'm taking
the front axle out and so we can remove
the front wheel exactly the same process
is the back except for the fact of these
pinch bolts in the fork so you take off
these pinch bolts in this plate
completely after taking the nut off of
the left-hand side and then you just tap
the axle and the wheel comes out a lot
of times if you're just removing the
front wheel depending on the setup you
might want to remove the front fender
first before removing the front wheel
this just happened to be easier today
[Music]
again same system as the back there's
front and rear disc brakes on this bike
just removing it from the fork leg now
we're down to almost a bare frame it's
just a matter of popping off the front
fender and taking off the front fork and
the bike will be completely disassembled
so here I am removing the front fender
again when you're doing this you wanna
be careful to make sure you don't
scratch anything careful of all the
paint that's the main thing when taking
apart a bike is you don't want to
scratch anything gonna damage anything
that's not going to be replaced and the
paint is definitely something you don't
want to have to do again
right now I'm moving the top nuts to the
fork tubes so they can slide out of the
triple tree one thing to be very careful
of as well and you're removing these
it's a hardened chrome slider it's a
hydraulic system you don't want to break
a seal or give it a reason to break a
seal anywhere area I'm just removing the
right side fork tube the triple tree is
the clamp that holds the fork tubes on
which lead down into the fork lowers or
fork legs and that's your whole steering
system right there this particular
system it's really common they're called
wide glide trees it's denoted by it's
the spacing between the fork tubes and
you pop the top caps off and then you
take off the pinch bolts on the lower
part of the triple tree and just slide
them out and now that the fork tubes are
removed you're gonna move the stem nut
for the triple tree once the nuts
removed you're gonna drop the bottom
tree out take the top tree off I don't
know when the last time it was ever
removed so it had to take a couple of
blows with the dead blow hammer the dead
blow hammer is nice because it has a
force behind it but it's also soft face
so it doesn't do any damage to the part
itself
now that were stripped down at the bare
frame the one thing that was left on was
the swing room which can be removed and
swapped out if need be but generally
there's no need to ever remove the swing
arm unless it's being replaced with
something else and that's it this is a
fully deconstructed harley-davidson
Shovelhead and it's all laid out here so
you can see the inner workings of the
motorcycle
my name is Ryan Jewell
I am asada and CW 21 certified
watchmaker working in New York City
today we're going to break apart these
two watches this is the side where the
magic happens for the watchmaker this is
where we're doing the majority of our
work the thing that people really like
about watch making is it's kind of the
incorporation of art and science it is a
craft and there is creativity involved
but then there's also times where there
are very strict guidelines that you have
to follow here are the two completely
disassembled movements side by side
[Music]